حرمان مشجع الانجليزي من الملاعب مدى
الحياه امال بكم تخيب بسبب ولده وبوجبا
يستعين بالقران بعد اصابته الجديده هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها عبر العربيه
الرياضه فاهلا بكم
تسببت اساءه موجهها مشجع عبرها وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لمهاجمي الانجليزي ايفل
تراني في الحكم عليه بحرمانه من دخول جميع
ملاعب انجلترا مدى الحياه كما يحضر عليه
السفر لحضور اي نشاط يتعلق بكره القدم
سواء كان وديا او دوريا خارج البلاد
المشجع البالغ من العمر 24 عاما وبسبب
اساءته العنصريه
تلقى حكما بالسجن لاربعه اشهر مع وقف
التنفيذ عامين ويعد هذا القرار اول قرار
يصدر بموجب بقانون الشرطه والجريمه الصادر
العام الماضي
اتجه الدوليه الانجليزيه السابق ديفيد
بكام الى ملعب يونايتد لمشاهده ابنه روميو
والذي يلعب لفريق في مباراه امام ارسنال
النجم الانجليزيه ظهر باناقه كبيره في
المدرجات الى جواري 500 وثلاثه عشر مشجعا
اخر لكنه احبط اذ لم يلعب ابنه روميو اي
دقيقه في المباراه التي انتهت بانتصار
برينتفورد بهدف
يواجه النرويجي ايرلينج هالاند مهاجر
ومانشستر سيتي الانجليزي بعد الانتقادات
لفتره الاخيره بداعي تدبب مستواه وانخفاض
معدله التاليفي
الالماني من الانتقادات الموجهه الى
هالاند اذ قال ان المهاجم النرويجي احرز
ثمانيه وعشرين هدفا خلال 26 مباراه في
بريميرليج اذا كنتم لا تريدونه فارسلوه
لنا ونحن سناخذه حتى لو لعشر مباريات
التي يتعرض لها بايه قرانيه
على انستجرام ايه من سوره البقره لا يكلف
الله نفسا الا وسعها وذلك بعد ان تعرض
لاصابه جديده جعلت الجماهيره تهاجمه بشكل
كبير لعدم استفاده يوفنتوس من
[موسيقى]